foreign
the Fourth of July is one of the busiest
holidays for air travel across the
United States
from coast to coast millions of
Americans will take to the skies in the
next few days
and this year it's shaping up to be even
busier as the aviation sector slowly
returns to its pre-pandemic levels
but it's the increasing cost of living
that's got many people worried I like to
travel every weekend but unfortunately
with inflation it's kind of hard to do
that I had to get back to see family I
haven't seen them since covid so it
really Wilson
a question we just had to do it but we
won't be going away for the rest of
Summer that's it now yeah for some
reaching their destination this weekend
with their hard-earned tickets is
proving more challenging I was flying
with Delta and they canceled my flight
as I'm boarding a plane our flight got
canceled yesterday so now we're
hopscotching around to get home we
actually got five
day out of Heathrow they canceled 30
flights so we've got a message from
United at quarter to midnight and we
were supposed to be flying at 8am in the
morning we were stranded two young
children
what do you think
the issue bad weather air traffic delays
and stopping shortages
and it's not just in the U.S airports
across Europe and the UK are struggling
to readjust after many workers left
their jobs during the pandemic
and many more went on strike in response
to the soaring costs of living
some countries like Germany have
launched schemes to bring in temporary
foreign workers Heathrow this morning
was an absolute mess
we were at the we were told to arrive
five hours before the flight to make
sure that we got on our flight and we
were just queuing the desk when open we
were just queuing the Keyser outside it
is horrendous there
back in the U.S with thousands of flight
cancellations and delays some airlines
are giving out bonuses for flight
attendants to ramp up Staffing others
are offering Pilots triple pay to pick
up extra trips
and for those left stranded they get
waivers to change their tickets for free
for those who prefer to skip the airport
during this busy holiday driving to
their destination seems to be a good
option
but with some of the highest gas prices
on record that may also prove costly
Jillian wolf Al Jazeera